so my science is basic science and what
that means is that I'm finding out how
something works at a very fundamental
level you know the physiology of it the
morphology of it the mechanics of it
whether it ends up at some point in time
helping to solve a problem we don't know
maybe maybe not but what it does is that
it contributes to this base of knowledge
that we have without which we would not
be able to solve problems at all
okay so science is not a linear process
it's not that if I want to cure cancer
you know the easiest ways to start from
A to B to Z it doesn't work that way you
need to have people who are having a
very broad base you know people who are
coming at it from different ways asking
different questions and then somebody
else comes in and they make an
unexpected connection and as you build
on that eventually you know somebody
comes up and they're like oh yeah this
this therapy that they're using for
something totally unrelated might be the
key to study this question and that's
just how how it goes and so without that
broad base of knowledge the people see
iceberg which is the finding those
applications which is simply go away and
so we can pick and choose from the
beginning and say well we're only going
to study things that we know are going
to have some benefits because we don't
know we don't know what we don't know
that's the whole point the whole point
of science and in the meantime we're
pushing the boundaries of our knowledge
and just figuring out okay so then how
do things work you know and and that's
that's important it's an important part
of what makes us human I think